and the oscar goes to
okay coda
what a win coda becomes the first film
with a predominantly deaf cast to win
best picture but that's not all the
casts are celebrating together as troy
coster became the first deaf male actor
to win best supporting honors hearing
people out there have neglected deaf
people
have really
been oblivious and haven't been involved
in deaf culture
and children of deaf adults and disabled
people have been there so much together
and so we have talent
and there are many ways to tell a story
from different perspectives and
different journeys
and i've just been trying to figure that
out because i just want to make a
connection that gives hollywood more
room for storytelling to think outside
of the box and he oscar goes too
ariana dubose
another historic moment ariana debose's
big win for her supporting role in west
side story she is the first openly queer
woman of color to win in the category
when you're the first of something it's
lonely
it's lonely
i mean at least that's what i've learned
sometimes so it's really
i don't know it's a privilege and it's
an honor and the oscar goes to
jane campion
and talk about girl power director jane
campion won best director for the power
of the dog she was the first woman ever
to be nominated twice for best director
and the oscars have now crowned two
women back to back with chloe zhao
winning last year for nomed land so just
to be another another woman
who's going to be followed by fourth or
fifth to sixth seventh and eighth i'm
very excited by the fact that this is
moving fast now
we need it equality matters